GREG HARTRELL: Thanks to
everybody for attending.
Today I want to spend
some time reflecting
on what we're seeing in the
games ecosystem in general
and observations around what
players are actually doing,
talk about the
archetypes that we see
and how your game
design can cater
to those archetypes
and a lot of the tools
that we have that allow
you to connect with them.
So before I prepped
for this talk,
I spent some time actually
watching people play games.
Turns out great opportunities
to work with many of you,
but also to get to see
people play all the fun stuff
that you make.
And some observations
are this-- mobile games,
by and large are still, on
average, a very single player
experience.
This is a portrait of a
child sitting on a couch
staring into a screen, very
single player lonely type
of experience.
And whatever the little girl
or the little boy is playing,
I promise you they won't
remember a year from now
what they were playing.
And that's a weird kind
of phenomenon for me
because when I reflect on the
games of say the '80s and '90s,
I remember playing with friends.
I remember playing
with families.
I remember running into
random people at arcades
and enjoying a very
social experience.
In the console biz, we created
this kind of gamer archetype,
right?
It's the guy sitting
in his basement
staring at a screen with
a controller in his hand.
And we put a headset
on this gamer persona
and we call that social.
But if you've played on
those types of experiences,
that experience usually involves
some 13-year-old screaming
something about your mother.
And that's not necessarily
the best experience.
We did a little better.
And then there was briefly
this phase in gaming
that we called social gaming.
We were all very excited
about the possibilities
of bringing people together.
I don't know how you
feel, but I never
had the day where sending
a putty knife to my friends
was a fun experience.
And it just turns that we see
less of those types of games
today as a result.
So the reality is that games
are better than this, right?
Ignore video games for a moment.
We know that games
have the capacity
to bring people
together in a way
that other types of mediums and
other types of entertainment
are not capable of.
And there's evidence around
us when you just take a look.
I quote Greek philosophers
to get immediate street cred,
you should too.
Plato uses this quote
where, you can discover more
about a person in an hour
of playing a game with them
then you can in a
year of conversation.
It's a profound statement
there, that perhaps
unlike any other
kind of medium, you
can connect with
people in a deeper way
with games then you can with any
other action you can think of.
A more academic version of
this is by a Dutch historian,
a guy named Johan Huizinga, if
I can pronounce that correctly.
And in this quote-- his thesis
of his seminal book called,
"Homo Ludens," which if you're
a Latin speaker, that loosely
translates into "man at play."
And the thesis of the book is
that playing in its own right
helps develop us
in ways that are
more fundamental to
the person that we are.
It shapes our personalities,
it shapes the relationships
that we create.
It even shapes the way that
communities come together.
And even at a meta level the
way nation states kind of work
with each other.
So all play, because
we're attracted
to playing with each other,
has meaning in that sense.
So it's a very profound kind
of way of looking at it.
And what those quote are
really supposed to demonstrate
is that playing games
together are fundamentally
a human trait.
We build friendships
around them.
We express ourselves
through them.
We build a sense of
belonging to a community when
we engage in those
types of experiences.
And if I again use the physical
world as a barometer for this,
there's some obvious
examples here.
I investigated retiring.
It's actually fantastic.
I think I'm going to
skip the whole work thing
and skip to retiring.
They're constantly
playing games, right?
Card games and board
games and anything
that they can get
their hands on.
They don't just merely
do it to pass away time.
The underlying tone here is it's
really to help groups of people
meet each other.
And you would otherwise not
know who this other person is
in this retirement community,
but you build a relationship
through games.
Games also have the capacity
to get large groups of people
to do really inane things.
This is a picture of-- so in
the Northeast United States,
there's Wall Street in
New York and it turns out
there's a neighborhood
of people there.
And every year at
Christmas, they
get together in do this
annual freeze tag event.
And so if you know what the
Northeast is like in the United
States-- there it gets
actually pretty cold.
But somehow they get
hundreds of people
out in the community to come
and play freeze tag events
because it's compelling to come
and play with a lot of people.
This is also a good example
of a physical world.
At MIT, they have this
annual mystery hunt
they've been running
since the 1980s.
And I think in the
last version, they
had about 2,000
participants with teams
ranging from 50 to 150 people.
And the goal of
the mystery hunt is
you solve all these very
archaic or arcane puzzles,
I should say.
And you eventually
solve all these riddles
to learn where some hidden
coin is around the campus.
And the reward for doing all
of these crazy puzzles that
involve mental and maybe
even real gymnastics
is that you get to write the
puzzles for next year's event.
And you see this graph
here where it just
shows the intensity of the teams
that are participating in this
solving puzzles
over a time series.
And it captures the essence of
large groups of people coming
together to experience a
really fantastic entertainment
experience.
And so the thesis is
basically, at their best,
games bring us together.
And when I look back
in video game history
there's really great examples of
where we did this really well.
There's the arcades of
old that brought together
random groups of people to play.
The more recent incarnation
is the bar-cade.
Some genius decided that they'll
take their love of arcades
and their love of
alcohol and combine them
into one establishment.
And so I'm glad to see that
kind of take a resurgence.
But living room
multiplayer games-- we
remember games like
"Goldeneye" and a lot
of the Nintendo products of old.
And of course, MMORPGs,
which in my mind
are really just
really elaborate chat
apps that have a game on top
of it while you're playing it,
right?
And of them have these
similar types of properties.
They bring people
together and it
keeps people engaged
in very deep way.
So if we accept that mobile
games are largely still
single player experiences
and playing games is human
and we've been better at
this before, the question is,
can we change?
Can we be more effective?
And what my thesis
is yes, we can.
And here's why.
You heard this stat from
Michael this morning
where we have a billion
active Android users.
This is 30-day
actives, not totals.
That's a massive active
community of people.
But use this stat as
your next measure here.
Three in four of those users are
playing games from Google Play.
That might be the largest
group of people playing
games ever put together.
And it of course makes
Google Play the best place
to grow and distribute your game
in the mobile ecosystem today.
But what these two
stats really tell
you is that really,
everybody's a gamer now, right?
It's not a demographic in a box.
It's not just 18 to
35-year-old males.
Anybody can play a game because
the device in your pocket
is capable of entertainment--
such rich entertainment.
And we have these cloud
services that can actually
connect people together
in a very deep way.
So the call to action
to me is really clear.
Let's make our
games social again.
Now here's the challenge.
If you have a
billion active users,
how do you succeed in
an ecosystem this large?
When you only had a
few million users,
it became a lot easier to think
about, well, what kind of game
am I making?
How am I going to
connect with them?
When you get into
the billions, it
becomes a much harder challenge.
And so this is the reason why
we made Google Play Games.
This is Google's game network
for Android iOS on the web.
And we announced recently
that this game network
added 100 million users in
just the last six months alone.
And that velocity, we're
very confident in saying
that it's the fastest
growing mobile game
network, perhaps ever.
And what's fascinating
about Play games
is that it fills this
really unique need
when you have an
ecosystem this large.
And that is-- you're creating a
concentrated network of people
who love playing games.
And as a result you want to
be able to connect into that
and get your content
exposed to them.
So since we launched it
at Google I/O in 2013,
developers have been integrating
services like achievements,
leaderboards, multiplayer
gifts, and newer services
like saved games
and quests to be
able to enhance the retention
and engagement of their games.
And we know that games are
doing better with those services
today.
More tangibly though,
Play games gets
you access to very high
quality gamers, people
who love playing games.
And that's the performance edge
you need it in an ecosystem
like we all see today.
We know when we look at
data for the developers who
have integrated game
services-- and I'll
take this moment to say that
if you have integrated them,
thank you, because you
are the reason why we've
been successful and
we love everything
that you've done
with game services
and we want to see you do more.
But tangibly, we
want to make sure
that the services are
actually providing value.
It's not just something
you throw into your game
because Google told you to.
We see these players, they play
longer, they play more often,
and they monetize
more frequently.
And that is a reason
alone to make sure
that you get your game
connected to those users.
And being able to see the
double digit percentage
increases we've seen in session
lengths and duration played.
And in some cases,
revenue bumps depending
on the types of designs
that you've chosen.
So this is where the question--
it's not merely a question of
did you integrate Play Games?
We all know that the game
that your designed matters
and the thematics and how
you approach your users still
works.
But how do you engage
a billion people?
So we've done number
of studies here
and one way to think about
this is that in this ecosystem
there's an openness
factor for how people want
to engage with
social interactions.
So there's people who want
to do very high levels
of social interaction
and very low.
And so we have these
three personas, right.
So I'll call them the
competitor, the completionist,
and the stealth gamer.
And you can plot
these personas, kind
of on that graph of
social openness, right?
With your competitor
being the most
open to being directly
competing with other people,
to your completionist
who's actually not
very interested in
competing with others,
but is more interested in
single player type interactions.
So I'll talk about these
three personas in more depth.
So the competitor is an
interesting kind of persona
because they'll engage in almost
everything in your game, right.
It's achievements, it's
leaderboards, it's multiplayer.
This is the person--
they own every console.
They set up their
social media page
to brag about the
achievements that they
earn from any platform
they earn it on.
And they're really engaged and
thrive in direct competition.
On the opposite
side of the spectrum
we have these
completionists, right.
These are people
who don't really
like engaging in any
kind of social activity.
However, they thrive in
progressing through your game.
They want to be
immersed in it, they
want to accomplish all the
goals that you give them.
They want to see the storyline.
They want to finish everything.
This is like the
mobile equivalent
of the gamer that wanted to
earn the "Geometry Wars" million
point achievement
without ever dying.
If you remember games
like "Final Fantasy VIII,"
there was that one summon
that you could do at the end
and it was like a
two minute video
that you had to watch
just to watch it cast.
And you had to complete
every last corner
and inch of the game to
be able to earn the right,
or the bragging
rights to do that.
That's this person, and
in mobile, they exist.
The last category
here, and they're
kind of in the middle
of this social openness
spectrum is what we
call the stealth gamer.
This one's a tricky
one because they're
the person you ask, hey are you
a gamer, and they're like, nah,
I'm not a gamer.
But then when you look
at them on a normal day
they're playing games every day.
This is like my mom, right.
She's like, no I
don't play games.
But she's sitting there
on her tablet every day
playing with random people.
And so what we know
about this persona
is that they will engage
in social interactions
but they will do so
passively, right.
The social interactions
have to be quick,
they have to be
relatively frictionless.
Or you have to kind
of involve them
in kind of like a community
type of atmosphere
as opposed to making
it more head-on
competition or something
that they would otherwise
be frightened of.
So with these three personas,
we can think of the tool kits
that we have with
the games network
and how we can connect
you to each one of them.
So I talked about the
competitor persona.
The toolkit you have here--
an obvious one is leaderboards
and we can talk about
turn-based multiplayer
and real-time multiplayer.
So the nice thing
about our leaderboards
is that we have social
and public leaderboards.
So public leaderboards are kind
of for your hardcore audience
because there's a set of
people who will always
compete to be number one.
For the average person, they
might never be number one.
But I could be number
one amongst my friends.
And so what's great
about your competitors,
they're going to intuitively
go for the top scores
but they're going to see their
friends leaderboard and say,
hey, I want to compete
with my friends.
They're more inclined
to invite them,
it's more likely to turn
into an acquisition for you.
And that's a fantastic
reason for leaderboards
to be implemented
into your games.
Encouraging the friends to
be invited into the game
is just another way to not
only engage the persona,
but to grow your
game incrementally.
Real-time
multiplayer-- if you're
building a synchronous game
this is a fantastic technology
that gets you into the ecosystem
in a very tangible way.
"NBA Jam" here-- if
you remember that game
from the '90s, now on mobile.
They implemented our
real-time multiplayer.
And what they use
really effectively
is what we call our
auto-matching feature.
And auto-matching-- the
way to think about it
is that you're getting
access to the hidden
social graph of the game.
It's basically
connecting people who
are playing actively right now.
And so you see incredible
boosts in engagement
because you're able to simulate
the arcade interaction of old,
but on a mobile medium.
And so you'll play
a game like NBA Jam,
you're playing one or two
sessions, you bail out
and then seconds later
you're connecting
with somebody else who's
available to play right now.
For a more, let's say
intimate experience,
you can still invite
friends directly in the game
and this is kind of a
screen shot of doing that.
Google will sort and rank users
depending on your interaction
with them recently.
So recent players
and active players
will show up at the top.
And friends who haven't
yet come to play the game
are deprioritized
in an effort to make
the match experience relevant.
For turn-based
multiplayer, it largely
follows a similar type of model.
Turn-based multiplayer
is much better for games
where the sessions can
be played in increments.
So maybe it's over
hours, or over days,
or it's literally
a turn-style game.
Same type of thing, except when
a turn is pending in the games
experiences that we have
in the Play Games app
and inside the game themselves,
this is a call to action
for me to come back.
So if I went on vacation
or I just got busy
and I didn't decide to
finish playing the game,
having that card sitting
in my inbox that says,
hey Dan's turn started reminds
me that I was playing this game
and is a call to action
for me to come back
and that's an important
retention point for you.
An important part of
turn-based and real-time,
though, is the social
discovery part of it.
And that is when
somebody invites me,
I do get a notification across
the entire Android ecosystem.
So the way that this works
is that we prioritize
how noisy the
notification is, depending
on whether I have a connection
with them and their circles,
or whether I don't
know them at all.
So here you can see Dan's
invited me on the left here.
And I see his face and I see
his name and it buzzes my phone
and it vibrates, and
great, Dan's there,
I'm going to go and play a game.
But somebody can invite me
who's not in my circles.
And I'll get a silent
notification in the shade
and when I pull that
down and I look at it,
it's like, OK, great, I'm
going to go see who invited me
and understand that I
want to play with them.
So when I dive into one
of those notifications,
you'll get an experience not
dissimilar to this, which
basically allows me to
start a game with somebody
I know-- Dan on the left.
Or somebody I don't know--
this stranger on the right.
Not really a stranger.
And I can decide whether I
want to play with them or not
or mute them or decline
or whatever have you.
But here's the growth hack.
If I don't have the game,
this will redirect you
to the Play Store.
And then someone's going
to install your game,
start getting playing that
they otherwise wouldn't.
And because it was
introduced to me by a friend,
they feel a lot more inclined
to start playing the game
because there's kind
of a social angle
to, well if Dan likes the game,
I should like the game too.
OK.
So we talked about the
competitor persona.
There's the other
side of the spectrum
which is the completionist.
There's two really important
ways to engage this user
and we just see it time and
time again through data.
Great achievement design
and supports saved games.
Great achievement
design-- the way
I always describe it is if I
finish a game like "Hit Men Go"
is the game really done?
And I could just turn it
away and forget about it.
But it turns out that when I
add achievements to my game
it allows me to explain to users
that there's more depth to it.
That there's more to do.
And so you can easily
come back and you can see,
here's some achievements that
I haven't quite finished.
They're still very incremental.
It gives me other
types of objectives,
it calls me back into the game.
And we've seen games with
great achievement design boost
monetization.
They've boosted engagement,
they've retained their users
in a deeper way
and consistently,
compared to games that don't
implement achievements,
they outperform them
almost every time.
If you want tips on
good achievement design,
we have a YouTube
video called, Game
On-- Achievement Point Pointers.
This is a good opportunity to
take a picture of the screen.
If you don't take a picture of
the screen, you can Google it.
It's a fantastic video by
our resident, Todd Kerpelman,
who is a former Pogo designer.
I mentioned saved games.
So this is kind of intuitive,
but you have these solo players
who increasingly, when
they're very engaged,
are switching between devices.
Our saved game system
works cross-platform.
And really, the
point of doing this
is that you never want somebody
to play level one again.
If they're going to switch a
device or buy a new device,
the worst situation is you'll
completely churn out your user
if they can't pick up
where they left off.
Or my other favorite example--
I think we've all experienced
this-- is you get the support
call if somebody says, hey
I thought that I would fix
the game if I just uninstalled
and reinstalled it, like
that works normally right?
And then you realize,
oh wait a second,
you've lost all your data.
You've basically reset
the game, there's
not very much I can do for you.
That's a bad experience.
Saved games completely
removes this.
And we consistently see this
as one of the top requests
from any one of our
players in Play Games.
Easy to implement, brain
dead from that perspective.
And here's what we added
at I/O-- the ability
to attach cover images.
So you'll see here this is
me playing "Leo's Fortune."
What they do is they
take a screenshot
of where I last left
off in the game.
So when I come back from
vacation and I scroll through
and say, hey, what game
do I want to go back to?
I see the screenshot that
reminds me, yeah, that's right,
I did left leave
off on level three.
I'm going to come
back and I'm going
to pick that game
over other ones
because I feel like I could
go back and probably win
that level.
So it's kind of a
digital bookmark
so that users can get
called back into action
and help you get a little bit
more of a re-engagement flavor
to your title.
While we're on the
topic of growth hacks,
I want to insert this one.
And this is the concept of
games your friends are playing.
This applies really
to all the personas,
but I'll call out-- because
the completionist is still
a play alone type
of player, they're
still attracted to this.
There's something
that's about, hey,
let me see what my
friends are playing.
It's a way for me
to discover games.
It's a denotion of maybe the
games have a higher quality,
or whatever have you.
So you see a screen shot here.
We have the Play Games app
where you can see games
that I've played recently, like
"Brave Frontier" or "Frozen
Front."
Or in the store where
you can see games
like "Heroes of Camelot"
and "Sky Force."
This is a very strong
call to action.
It's zero effort to you, other
than implementing Play Games.
We take the signals,
we pour them
into our discovery
channels and help
your name get better discovered.
And so if you're
into growth hacks,
finding those extra percentage
points of additional user
acquisition, this is a very
easy thing to do for your game.
OK.
And so that brings me
to the stealth persona.
So we talked about
how the stealth
persona is kind
of tricky, right.
They don't like the
direct social engagement,
so you can't use like the old
memes of direct competition.
They don't think of
themselves as a gamer,
but they play all the time.
But we have a few
tools that we think
will constantly
resonate with them.
So the first one is that we
created a game gift system.
We know from our research that
if the social interactions are
extremely discreet,
very easy to get into,
and low friction
Game Gifts is a way
to kind of trade a quick
object between two players
and keep them engaged and
invite them into the game.
And this service
is pretty simple.
I can just kind of
visualize it this way
is that when you
implement it, players
select a gift that they
send to another player.
We store if for seven
days on our server.
And we send a notification
in a similar type of way
that we do for multiplayer.
When the other user receives the
notification, they tap through,
they select the gift
that they want to play.
And similar to what
we did in multiplayer.
It will ask them to install
the game if they don't already
have it.
So it's a great opportunity
for another social acquisition.
But it's also something that
resonates with this persona
because I'm not
getting challenged.
I'm not being put on the spot to
be able to do this right away.
It's a very simple thing.
Oh, I'm receiving
something from somebody.
That sounds kind of cool.
Don't send them putty
knives, by the way.
I don't want any putty knives.
And then ultimately,
they receive the gift,
they're elated, and they
get engaged into the game.
And you can recreate
the experience inside
of your own game like we do
with any one of our other APIs.
Another service that we
launched is called Quests.
And the way to think
about Quests first of all,
it's a way to create time-based
objectives in your game
without having to
update the game.
And what it does is it creates
this community feeling, right.
There's a lot of people doing
this big kind of community
event on a weekend.
Sometimes this is
referred to as live-off.
So this might be thought
of as live-offs in a box.
But the way we've
implemented this
is that it's analytics driven.
So the way Quest works is
that you send the Quest system
events of what's
going on in a game.
When somebody levels up, when
they modify their sword, when
they find the rare black
sheep in your game.
And through learning what
players are doing inside
of the game, you can
craft quests then
you run in a time span,
like on a weekend,
or for an entire week based
entirely off of that data.
I'll show you how this works.
So you start by
defining a set of events
that happened in your game.
Let's say I'm
making a zombie game
and I have red, green,
and blue zombies.
And so I would fire an
event every time somebody
killed one of those
three colors of zombies.
And I integrated that in my
game and the Quest interfaces
exists to show a user when
a new quest is available.
Then I monitor those events.
So let's say I'm pretty
satisfied with the number
of red zombies and green zombies
being killed in the game,
but I'm not really happy with
the number of blue zombies
being killed, because there's
more monetization events tied
to them, they're
harder to kill, people
have a tendency of buying
more things in my game
because they're harder
to kill in general.
So I can go into the
developer console
and create a Quest
that's like, hey, we're
going to have a 5,000 zombie
blue zombie killing fest
this weekend.
And the Quest system will track
every time somebody's completed
killing an existing blue zombie.
And when you
accomplish that goal,
it can push down a custom
blob of data to your game
that you can
interpret and decide
how you want to
reward your users.
So common examples would
be a blob that says,
grant in-game currency
to the user who succeeds.
Or give them some
kind of in-game reward
or progress them through the
game in a new type of way.
The best part
about this, though,
is I didn't have to update my
game at any moment in time.
It's entirely based on
just sending the events
and the quests
automatically populate
in the Quest UI
that's integrated.
And so you could run
these quests every day,
every week, every weekend and
constantly reengage your users.
But use the data to decide which
quests are the most effective,
and are you helping shape the
behavior of your users in a way
that you're retaining
and engaging them more?
We had one developer who showed
their Quest data recently
and they saw users that engage
in quests went on to do,
I think it was 160% more
other types of sessions
in their game, just by virtue
of engaging them in this way.
So I highly advise--
it's a dynamite feature
if you're in to live-ops.
Very easy to implement
and everything
is documented on
developers.google.com.
The last thing that
I want to talk about
is, of course-- OK, we've
got these three personas,
we have all these tools.
How do you know
you're successful?
So you have to have a
way to measure success.
So Google-- we're a very
data driven company.
Game developers who
were wildly successful
are also very data driven.
One way that we help
you here is-- you're
familiar, probably with the
statistics we have in the Play
console today.
But there's a
separate game focused
set of statistics that are
given to you just by virtue
of integrating Play games.
And so when you
implement Play Games,
there's basically a zero effort
dashboard that's given to you.
I'll dive into it
a little deeper.
So for example,
your daily dashboard
gives you a summary
of your active users,
your new users, retention.
And more recently we've
added demographic data.
The demographic data-- when
we hear from developers
is essential because as a game
designer you want to know,
hey, is this game actually
resonating with the audience
I thought that was
going to be playing it?
If I made a game that
I expected females
between the ages of
18 and 30 to play,
I would hope my data
would show that.
Another angle here is that if
you're into user acquisition
and you're trying to come
up with the right type
of creative assets, knowing
what kind of demographic
your game has, in
reality, can help
you decide what kind
of creatives you use
and how you engage and go
after the right audience.
Another essential here is
our retention dashboard.
This is for your ability
to retain new users.
So a common example
here is that you
want to take a look at how many
new users are coming back--
day one, day two,
day seven, day 30.
And so you can
kind of understand
the attrition rate of your game.
And let's say that you had
a tutorial in your game
and you wanted to try and
improve that in an effort
to help people get back on day
one and day two more often.
Here you would see, you
know, on March 8 here,
I did an update to my
game the day before
and I saw a boost in my metrics
because apparently my tutorial
was better at convincing
people to stick around.
And that's a use
case for this data.
Again it comes from just
integrating Play Games
and having people sign in.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a formula for that?
GREG HARTRELL: The formula?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
GREG HARTRELL: Yeah,
this one's simple, right.
It's basically that you
have a cohort of new users
that came in on a specific day.
Here's the percentage
that came back day
one, day two, day three.
It's a simple multiplier.
The last one is in
the engagement stats.
Today we support achievements
and leaderboards.
So when you think about
engaging these personas
you also want to use the data
to know that you're effectively
doing that.
So you can see whether the
achievements that you added
to your game recently are
actually getting earned.
Whether they're too
difficult, whether it
takes too long to earn them.
Or if you're into the
competitor type of persona,
maybe you have a
custom leaderboard
for some very special
part of the game
and this is a way for you to get
an indicator of whether they're
actually engaged
in that content.
And whether the changes that
you're making to your game
design are actually resonating
with that type of user.
All right.
So I'll wrap up.
The summary today is
basically this-- Google Play
games connects your game to
a highly concentrated network
of very high quality gamers.
We have the services,
achievements, leaderboards,
multiplayer, and gifts.
And the new stuff like
saved games and quests.
And they're all showing us
data that games are increasing
engagement and retention
in very dramatic ways.
These players play longer,
they play more often,
they monetize more frequently.
And the service can cater
to those three personas
if you're very deliberate
about in your design.
But going back to the
beginning of this-- remember,
everybody's a gamer now.
We have a billion
of them out there.
And that makes this a much
more challenging, but also
a very exciting time for us.
Android and Google Play
have created an ecosystem
that large that gives you
that kind of opportunity.
And we know that games at their
best have brought us together.
And so if I leave you
with one message today
it's, go forth and
make your game social.
And with that-- if you
have any questions for me,
I'll be wandering outside, happy
to talk with every one of you.